Bien, pues esta es tu oportunidad de utilizar
una balanza para saber cuanto pesa un objeto,
bueno, en este caso vamos a pesar este amiguito verde que está aquí, que se llama Viejo Lobo de Mar
y de hecho es lo que nos preguntan,
¿Cuánto pesa Viejo Lobo de Mar?
Y lo que podemos observar es que la balanza está en equilibrio y luego nos dicen que
Viejo Lobo de Mar su peso más 6 bloques
es igual a 8 bloques.
De lo que se trata es quitar o poner bloques...
bueno ya veremos que hacemos...
de manera que tengamos solo de un lado a Viejo Lobo
de Mar, del otro lado los bloques que correspondan,
la balanza se encuentra en equilibrio y así
sabremos cuanto pesa Viejo Lobo de Mar.
Pero hagamos primero una exploración, por ejemplo, ¿qué pasa si yo quito un bloque del lado derecho?
¡Ups!
Bueno, si yo quito un bloque del lado derecho
éste sube y claro, perdimos el equilibrio,
de hecho nuestra expresión, ahora nos dice
que no tenemos una igualdad, pero bien,
estamos explorando.
Entonces lo que yo voy a hacer es regresar
el bloque que había quitado y de acuerdo,
todo está en equilibrio, entonces ahora del
lado izquierdo, voy a quitar un bloque,
pero definitivamente tengo que hacer algo, si yo
quito algo del lado izquierdo,
tengo que hacerlo del lado derecho también.
Entonces, ahora vamos con el lado derecho...
¡perfecto!
ahora vamos otra vez con el lado izquierdo...
otra vez con el derecho, muy bien, vamos muy bien.
Quito otro del lado izquierdo y otro del lado derecho...
lo repito...
otra vez...
una vez más...
ya nos estamos acercando, eh...
¡y por fin!
¡lo logramos!
La balanza está en equilibrio y Viejo Lobo
de Mar pesa 2 bloques y bueno en este ejercicio
que puedes hacer en nuestro sitio te estamos
proporcionando toda una serie de información
de todo lo que ocurrió, de hecho empezamos
con esta expresión que se encuentra aquí
y lo que hicimos fue, restar 6 de ambos lados,
como puedo observar aquí,
y finalmente para llegar a la solución que Viejo Lobo de Mar o también podemos llamarle "x" tiene un valor de 2.
Bueno, es el momento de comprobarlo.
¡Y todo salió muy bien!
Nos vemos en el próximo video.